Now let's talk about different approaches to operating system
structuring. The first structure that I will introduce to
you is what we will call as a monolithic
structure. You have the hardware at the bottom which
is managed by the operating system and hardware includes,
of course, the CPU, memory, peripheral devices such as
the network and storage and so on. And there
are applications at the top. And each of these applications
is in its own hardware address space. What that means is that every application
is protected from one another because the
hardware ensures that the address space occupied by
one application is different from the other
applications and that is the first level
of protection that you get between the
applications themselves. And all the services that applications
expect from the operating system are contained in this blob and that might
include file system and network access, scheduling
these applications on the available CPU, virtual
memory management, and access to other peripheral
devices. The OS itself of course is
a program providing entry points for the
applications for the services that are expected
by the applications. And code and the data structure of the operating system is
contained in its own hardware address space. What that means is that the
operating system is protected from the applications
and vise versa. So even if an
application were to do anything in terms
of misbehavior, either maliciously or unintentionally because
they are in there own address spaces and the operating system is in its
own hardware address space. Malfunctioning of an
application does not affect the integrity of the
operating system services. That is, when an
application needs any system service, we switch from
the hardware address space that is representing
this particular application, into the hardware address space
of the operating system. And execute the system
code that provides the service that that is
expected by the application. For example, accessing the
file from the hard disk, or dynamic allocation
of more memory that an application may want,
or sending a message on the network. All
of these things are done within the confines
of the address space of the operating system itself.
Note that all of the services expected of the operating system,
file system, memory management, CPU scheduling, network and so on, are all
contained in this one big blob. And that is the reason it's
also sometimes referred to as the monolithic structure of an operating system.